Casa Mia you managed to excite in a way
that very few Russians do but you're
only going to be highly successful when
your customers are with you sometimes
you step too far and you forget the
customers
Prasad
Cousy your heart is bigger than any
woman's I ever known you're too generous
put more in the till yeah and stop
giving it away
okay that's been my experience I'm
starting to finish it's been a
tempestuous journey based on everything
I've experienced tasted witnessed
the winner and a mighty congratulations
goes to Casa Mia well done
Kelsi Prasad
my vow matters for you congratulations
well done well done my darling well done
Bobby well done
Casa Mia John right Pete congratulations
well well deserves well done well done
well done well done well done well done
well done
come here well good good job good job
well done well done just amazing map see
it means this is unbelievable so dream
come true sir I just sooo glove
my boys just put everything we could
into MC everything I mean I'll never
give so much energy and passion into
dishes ax my life mystery I know you're
disappointed mark I know but we haven't
lost became second remember your two in
12,000 month - yeah we are disappointed
but Prasad need to blow we want to learn
more and we we going to be success one
day I'm talking gutted for Prasad here
you've got to self towards ladies that
cooked here tonight as if they were
cooking for their lives that feels
amazing
Rashad was up against two real
thoroughbreds that are going to leave
her a lasting impression the relevance
of that dinner tonight
that was our three-star standard between
missions fast and the wish chefs spent
25 30 years to perfect this is Hugh
because back to us what you've allayed
me and Pete to do and the direction you
are Richard you kind of the direction in
the vision you had on kind of what me
and people what is to do with food and
allow us to do it
don't mess my [ __ ] via Susan so say
Marcin yeah I trust your boys I trust
you
I could see the talent
tonight for Pacquiao and Susan was
payback night because their sons proved
why their mum and dad have backed them
all away and tonight they've shown I
mean they really shot